[موسيقى]
خلال العشرين سنه المنصمه تقريبا حصل
عندنا تغيرات مناخيه لم تكن مكتوبه في
السجلات المناخيه المدونه او محفوظه في
ذاكره كبار السن المرويه جريان متتالي
لاوديه لا تجري الا على فترات متباعده مثل
وادي الرمه جرى ها السنه مرتين ربيع على
نجد تهامه والمعروف انه اذا ربع التهامه
اجدبت نجد والعكس صحيح
[موسيقى]
والعلماء حيال هذه التغيرات اقوال عده
اهمها من العلماء من قال ان هذه التغيرات
امور طبيعيه وهي تتبع نظام الدورات
المناخيه العظمى والتي مدتها 75 سنه فكلما
انتهى الدوره مناخيه عظمى منصرمه وبدات
دوره مناخيه عظمى جديده فان السماء تتمخض
لولاده هذه الفتره وهذا التمخر هو التغير
ومن العلماء من قال ان البشر هم اساس
البلاء بما احدثوه من ثوره صناعيه وما
ناتج عنها من ادخنه عملت على خلخله عناصر
المنظومه المناخيه
[موسيقى]